[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to swipe here's what's in store
for you this week connecting you now we
sank it to get the lowdown on the
American gadget replacing British
payphones meanwhile I find out how
supermarket brands are using virtual
reality to influence what you buy and
cray toss is back but he needs to learn
to control his anger can Simon help him
calm down find out in our games review
stay with us for all of that and more
first though let's get a look at the
tech stories that got us talking this
week a robot has taken less than nine
minutes to complete one of the hardest
jobs known to man assembling a flat-pack
IKEA chair a team of researchers from
Singapore's Nanyang Technological
University developed the robotic arms
which have 3d eyes nimble fingers and
pressure sensors that control how much
force they exert scientists have
engineered an enzyme that eats plastic
it degrades the type of plastic that
bottles are made from the kind that can
last for hundreds of years polluting our
environment researchers at the
University of Portsmouth and the US
Department of Energy's National
Renewable Energy Laboratory who made the
discovery are hoping to now optimize it
to use on an industrial scale it's being
called the fastest growing language in
history but are emojis damaging people's
English skills research by YouTube shows
nearly everyone surveyed agreed that
there had been a decline in the correct
use of English it also found nearly
three-quarters of adults depend on
emojis to communicate and finally an
update on this previous flight story
remember the Virtual Reality project for
people with dementia that recreated the
day of the Queen's coronation in VR
while the team behind the wayback
project are now crowdfunding on
Kickstarter to help them make their next
memory film this time it'll be the
lead-up to the World Cup final in
in 66 the series is designed to trigger
memories and conversations in those
living without silence now when was the
last time you used one of these if the
answers never you're not alone they used
to be almost a hundred thousand of them
across the country and now there's fewer
than half that number but in an attempt
to keep them relevant BT has been
replacing hundreds of them with
high-tech versions from New York
although not everybody is happy about
that as kids has been finding out for
this many people in remote communities
would be shut off from the world the way
we communicate has been transformed
since this ad was on our screens in the
1980s and the phone box is no longer the
essential daily tool it once was so now
hundreds are being replaced with
something completely different in the
dead of night a small army of workers
who are moving old boxes on street
corners up and down the country and BT
has made a long-distance call to New
York for its new model they're called in
links an intersection a firm backed by
Google's owner alphabet has been
replacing the Big Apple's payphones with
them for the past two years and they
aren't really payphones at all because
they actually offer free calls and Wi-Fi
paid for by advertising for some that
offer has rung alarm bells and charge
your phone and get some Wi-Fi this group
has campaigned against them because of
concerns they gather too much personal
data
[Music]
the head of in link UK Matt Burd told me
he's keen not to repeat the same
mistakes on this side of the Atlantic we
have no interest whatsoever of tracking
individuals whether it's on Wi-Fi or
other means so will we care about
utilizing data for good and that's about
aggregated anonymize not about tracking
individuals so we have no interest in
doing that I feel quite comfortable to
stand here today and say that that's not
our interest that's not what we've been
asked to do and our business model as
we're paid for by the advertising on the
blue meat the main media screens not
from the individuals themselves the
technology and classic red phone boxes
like this hasn't actually changed much
since they were first introduced in the
1920s but their futuristic replacement
has been specifically designed so it can
be adapted and evolved with new
technology over time and that's
something that critics say we should be
concerned about campaigners have been
opposing some of the planning
applications for the new kiosks in
London Ross at Caen who designs street
furniture has concerns about how they
could be adapted I started to realize
that these weren't just phone box
replacements they were actually an
incredible sensor network that's being
deployed through the city they were
going to be over 750 of these installs
and and they've said that there are
platforms that they're gonna fill with
more and more sensitive stuff
you know they'd be public about that and
so they're building this incredible data
gathering network throughout the city
and yet people are treating them like oh
yeah we're just replacing if I blog with
plans for almost a thousand inmates on
our pavements by the end of the year
you're likely to see one on a street
corner near you very soon and then you
can make your own call and whether there
are data gather info or a fitting
replacement for the good old phone box
Virtual Sky News have you ever wondered
what goes on at a retail a virtual
reality lab
no me neither and then I found out what
they are
turns out these specialist labs aware
retailers and brands figure out ways to
influence our behavior when we're out
shopping and encourage us to splash the
cash here's how hi there yes Neal here
is about to become a shopping guinea pig
he's been set a mission to buy a box of
chocolates for his own special reason
just migrans birthday coming up yeah
he'll be choosing his grand Chocolat in
a virtual supermarket because the point
of this task is to see how shoppers like
Neal behave what products attract them
the most and how they respond to
different store layouts the feedback is
valuable information for food and drink
brands and retailers vying for your
attention and ultimately your cash you
can pick up these products just like you
wouldn't a normal store actually look at
them closely you can see the prices you
can look at calorie content if you were
him if he um if you wants to and why is
using a headset better than just
watching Neal walk around a real-life
supermarket and seeing what he chooses
yeah well you know in a real supermarket
you can only test what's in store
actually at that time and what you want
to do if you're a brand or a retailer is
test what's gonna happen in the future
the new product launch you've got the
new packaging the new design of the
store I mean virtual reality you could
design multiple different new retail
ideas the other thing is what you can do
with virtual reality is include eye
tracking now if we asked Nia laughs to
us what he did and what he store he's
only remember certain things and he may
not even notice what he actually looks
at but the eye tracking was has exactly
what he saw in store they're also using
heat mapping red marks the items most
looked at by test shoppers behind a
large pane of one-way glass
shopping behavior expert ivan is
observing Neil's decision making it's
Ivan whose job it is to translate the
results to the brand that wants to win
your attention what might a brand or a
retailer actually do with the
they get there what kind of changes what
they made they can really change
anything they want to within the store
environment so they could look at where
particular types of products are placed
in the store should there be at the
front of the store or the back of the
store if we know from his visual
activity that he's more likely to see
one color versus another we could change
the packaging at the box to be that
color we could be looking at what
elements of the box he looks at so it
may not just be the color it might be
the branding isn't big enough on it or
it could be that the messaging on there
isn't clear enough for the shopper so we
can change all of those elements that
potentially can drive how that product
stands out at shelf
I know that's a reality yeah did it feel
anything like a real supermarket yeah it
did it was really realistic the biggest
question that I'm thinking of right now
is what are you gonna get your ground
for her birthday
not a box of chocolates I think brace
yourselves now there's a Spartan warrior
fighting multiple enemies in this week's
games review and that's just the start
here's Simon with his take on some of
the latest releases can you kill
something that big
you're a war for the PlayStation 4 is
the coming back of the franchise to the
console and I'm happy to tell you not
only is it a fantastic game in its own
right but it's also one of the best
games of the entire generation as ever
you do step into the shoes of Kratos and
like before combat and the action the
adventure here are really good crayons
is a really angry man he just goes
around he's got loads of weapons and you
just kill anything that comes at you
have it's very well developed and
therefore you're gonna enjoy yourself
but change this time around is that
Kratos isn't by himself
Norman he's got a Charlie's now why
doesn't really sound like god of war the
point is it's so emotional it's so
involving by the time the end credits
roll you're genuinely gonna have been
sucked in by this end you're gonna
appreciate Kratos more as a character
that was clearly the idea here and I
tell you Sony's pulled it off
wonderfully it's so good if you don't
own a PlayStation 4 console but you like
the sound of this it's probably worth
buying one because genuinely this could
be one of the best games not only of
2018 but maybe just maybe of all time so
in short God of War is a very good video
game your kids are 6 the song of life
for the PlayStation 4 is another entry
in the Yakuza franchise and maybe even
the last one but if it is Sega has done
a great job with this it's a very good
video game and all fans of the accuser
franchise are going to be very pleased
if you've never played at your Cuza game
before it's your standard
action-adventure experience so you're
gonna be doing some combat you're gonna
be doing some exploration you're gonna
be doing some detective work and you're
gonna be stepping into the shoes of
kazuma and just enjoying his story
really but it's all very very well told
it's all very to the point it's all very
straightforward and while if you are a
fan of the series you may be getting a
little bit bored it does put very
similar to other games in the series
it's still good it's still been a good
job you still gonna have a good time
the best thing about your cooze r6 as
well is if you've never played any of
the other games while you do need to do
a little bit of reading around this you
can play this as well and Sega has
deliberately done that so not only is it
good for fans of the series but it's
accessible as well and what more can you
ask for that Yakuza 6 are very good
Yakuza game
MLB deshou 18 for the place they support
can actually be summed up in one single
sentence and that's this it's the best
baseball video game ever made
now while on the one hand that's not
actually that impressive cuz there
aren't that many baseball games I don't
mean it like that and I genuinely mean
that in terms of a simulation of the
sport this couldn't be any better and
that's not just from the act of taking a
bat and hitting a ball either there's so
much depth here and so many moat if you
like baseball you could lose an entire
year of your life to this and you're
never going to get bored of it and yeah
there isn't too much of a difference
between this year's game in the previous
century but that's not the point because
what is here is really good to sum it up
all I need to say is this if you're a
football fan more often you're like FIFA
and if you're a baseball fan morph or
not you're gonna like MLB this show the
2018 version that's great again do you
like baseball go and get this it's as
simple as that I promise you you're
gonna have a good time with it if you
don't well you probably don't like
baseball well that's it for this week's
show don't forget to join us again for
more swype next week and in the meantime
why not follow us on twitter at Sky News
swipe then you can see what we get up to
throughout the week bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]